for being here my name is David Scalia
I'm professor of ecology and associate
dean for research in the school and on
behalf of Dean Peter crane and everyone
else I'd like to welcome you to our
event on hydraulic fracturing this is
much more than a one-hour plus event
this is something that a whole bunch of
people had a lot of input into going
back to last spring and I'm gratified to
say that the response to the community
by giving some early attention to this
the faculty and especially the students
have latched on to the idea that an
event like this with great participants
can also kind of feed into the other
things that are going on in the life of
the school and I'm sure that will come
up as the evening goes on here I have a
few people to thank and then I'm gonna
step out of the way I'm going to
introduce our moderator in just a moment
most importantly I want to thank
Bethenny's EMPA for all of the work that
she's done in organizing this event and
helping her along have been an enormous
number of staff and especially students
there are dozens and dozens of students
who have put many many many tens and
hundreds of hours into getting ready for
this moment right now many staff as well
I'd like to single out Stewart dequeue
and the Center for business environment
at Yale and just to give you a flavor of
some of what's going on offline related
to this event Stewart and his team are
working with Yale School of Management
and folks at Cornell to develop a case
study that's going to be inspired by
what's going on here today and go well
beyond it I'd also like to thank our FBS
communications and IT teams for making
everything go perfectly so far and the
Yale broadcast studio for helping us to
get the message out on this stuff and
now I'll turn to a great pleasure in
introducing Brad Gentry so Brad arrived
at Yale I think we worked out about six
months before I did in 1995 but I think
of him because he got here before me as
as part of the old guard which probably
isn't fair brad has
been involved in all aspects of the
school that you can possibly imagine and
is a real kind of catalytic point for
exactly what we're doing here today
so he's going to be making sure everyone
else gets their say today but let me
just point out that this is a very
talented individual that we've been able
to coax into playing this role today
he's director of yells center for
business and in the environment he's
also a professor in the practice at our
school here he's trained as a biologist
and as an attorney I'll leave you to
draw your own conclusions about what
went wrong there and his work focuses in
particular ways to increase investment
in improved environmental performance
Brad somebody who kind of knows the
concepts he knows the theory but he is
he's also a really pragmatic person so
he deals in in different aspects of his
work life with governments business NGO
he's also a very popular teacher here at
the school focusing on multi
disciplinary courses on managing fresh
water emerging markets for ecosystem
services as well as the legal financial
and managerial strategies for conserving
land and so I'm gonna ask you to thank
all the folks who made today happen and
also to thank Brad Gentry for his
contribution
the topic for our panel today is
hydraulic fracturing up reach to a clean
energy future it's exactly the type of
issue that we have the school want to
bring out and events like these vitally
important controversial deserving a
critical to be across a range of
perspectives including those we've
gathered for our panel today let me just
talk briefly about format
I'm going to start by asking each
panelist to give a short answer to this
overarching question of reach to a clean
energy future I'll then follow up with a
first round of questions to each of the
panelists to offer the other panelists a
chance to comment and then the students
who have been working so hard to collect
questions offline and from the cards
that were given to each of you I will
pass them to me for asking and by then
it will be 5:30 I ensure and wine will
be flowing out through the space behind
us before I introduce our panelists and
just to make sure we're all starting
from the same page
I did ask Jim stairs for a basic
definition of hydraulic fracturing just
to make sure we all are working from the
same well spot a process used to extract
gas or oil that involves creation of
fractures in a rock layer through a
rapid injection of pressurized fluid and
that's the question we're going to
explore with our panelists today and
what a wonderful group we have Jim at
the RN is a professor
hydrology here at the School of Forestry
and environmental studies he publishes
extensively on the factors affecting the
circulation of fresh water the transport
of contaminants and other chemicals in
streams weapons and armours Jim also
grew up in Port Allegheny a to traffic
like a town sitting on top of the
Marcellus Shale field so not
surprisingly a lot of Jim's work seeks
to improve our understanding of the
water quality and water supply impacts
of us Marcellus shale gas development
and it helped devise practices that
minimize these impacts in order to
protect access to safe drinking water
and health of freshwater ecosystems
Sheila Olmstead is an environmental
economist and a fellow at resources for
the future in Washington DC before
joining rff in 2010 Sheila was an
associate professor here at school and
the girls have it back today Sheila's
current research examines among other
things the environmental externalities
associated with shale gas development in
the United States as well as regulatory
winds under the US state reading Water
Act and a number of other issues her
research has been published in many
leading journals and along with natural
Hannum she's the author of the 2007 and
book markets and the environment she's a
member of water Directors Association of
environmental resource of promise as
well as the Advisory Board of the
International Water Resource Economics
consortium
John Hofmeister mr. Jim is a former
president of the Shell Oil Company and a
founder a not-for-profit nationwide
anniversary
Association citizens for affordable
energy as president of Shell he launched
an expensive outreach program involving
an 18-month 50 city tour across the
country in which John and 250 others
shell leaders met with more than 15,000
business community civic leaders
policymakers and academics to discuss
what should be done to ensure affordable
available energy for the future can you
us as head of citizens for affordable
energy John continues to promote sound
US energy security solutions for our
nation
including a range of affordable energy
supplies efficiency improvements
essential infrastructure sustainable
environmental policies and publication
and public education on energy issues
John is also the author of a wonderfully
titled work why are we heat the oil
companies straight talk from an energy
insider and serves on several boards
including that of the United States
Energy Security Council Bill McKibben is
the Schumann distinguished scholar at
Middlebury College and the author of
dozen books about the environment
beginning in 1989 with the end of nature
regarded as the first book for a general
audience on climate change he's also a
founder of grassroots climate
organization 350.org which is
coordinated over 15,000 rallies and 189
countries
since 2009 a tireless advocate on behalf
of the planet Time magazine called the
planets best for you journalists and in
2010 the Boston Globe so that those
probably the country's most important
environmentalist
so given this range of experience and
expertise you can see worse why our sort
start excited about today's panel so
let's get started each panelist now has
three to five minutes to offer their
answer to the question of whether
hydraulic fracturing is a bridge to a
clean energy future
we'll start with Jim Susheela John thank
Brett hydraulic fracturing has the
potential to unlock tremendous volumes
of natural gas from shale very basic
spread throughout the world this crust
is she owned the United States made
natural gas very affordable but there
are trade-offs shale gas like all fossil
fuels is dirty his combustion generates
carbon dioxide a gaseous waste that we
as a nation that failed to manage and
that it's overheating are playing the
notion that she'll get that the shale
gas boom will lead to US energy
independence is a myth and natural gas
me cheap by hydraulic fracturing a lower
deployment of renewables in the absence
of protective policies it's a local
level sloppy practices of some shale gas
producers have led to the pollution of
household drinking water wells by
methane the effects of this
contamination and other birds are born
unequally by the populace and store the
Bologna's we produce shale gas these
inequalities Taric to social fabric of
small towns that host shale gas
extraction these are facts and it's back
threes too but is but it is equally true
that the greenhouse gas footprint of
modern gas part electric power plants is
threefold smaller than the coal-fired
power plants that are now displaced
moreover combustion of natural gas
unlike combustion of coal emits no life
threatening mercury and substantially
less smog forming particulates in sulfur
dioxide it is also true the US
manufacturing cannot thrive at
affordable
gasps and the low-priced batchi gasp
maybe millions of low-income family to
heat their homes and tap water and while
tragic for those individuals affected
incidences of drinking water
contamination caused by shale gas
extraction are in fact rare and
decreasing in frequency is more
expensive gas call construction and
waste disposal standards are set in
place the good and bad of shale gas
development walk hand in hand there's
more than one side of this complex story
and has plenty of room for debate
however the debate over whether the bad
outweighs the good or vice-versa is a
distraction that prevents us from
attending to one important reality that
is natural gas will surely be a part of
the u.s. worldwide energy portfolio for
decades to come and shale gas extraction
will endure in areas where it occurs now
and it will expand to other regions
perhaps not to your neighborhood or
community but to other parts of the
United States in the world
thus the essential issue is not whether
shale gas is good or whether it's bad is
inherently neither rather the issue the
command our attention involves managing
shale gas development to minimize the
negative impact on the environment and
shaping an energy policy that the most
natural gas displacement of dirty fossil
fuels allowing for the growth of carbon
three renewables we were asked to
address in our opening comments the
following question a shale gas a bridge
to a clean energy future or simply a
bridge to a future resembling a bleeder
more spoil version of today this future
is not an employment shale gas
development will proceed however our
future will be determined less by this
inevitability than by the management and
policy choices we made going forward
she kind of questions uh giving people
an opportunity to comment on each
other's talents but we thought we'd get
everybody out there which breathing
absent me talk a little bit more about
specific details on the Russian about
whether in fact this vast resource of
domestic fossil fuel resources is a
bridge to a clean energy future and the
first thing I'd say is that ascribe
mention in this definition of hydraulic
fracturing that term or that
technologies he's not just an expression
of gas but also determining other who
takes the possible resources including
shale oil and so there's a sort of
broader question about technology most
of my concerns and involvement comes
today to the additional gas but some of
them will be relevant to other resources
like you know they're being extracted
using the same technology and many
others will not example the comments
about carbon tuition articulated in his
talk
so anything to say when we ask whether
shale gas is a bridge to energy future
we've given you many different things
the first thing and I think one thing
that a lot of people mean when they say
that is a bridge to a low-carbon future
and they're I think really the jury's
still out
and the Jerusalem for two reasons the
first is that is certainly true
the 90s combustion produces less carbon
emissions than coal for example and so
in that sense it's really a perfectly
respectable climate but also natural gas
is methane methane is office of regional
scales and in fact as I heard we're
going with digital in carbon at least in
the short run and so that was a really
important questions raised about the
lifecycle sense whether when you're
supplying actually asks when you start
to finish and you compare that to pull
after combustion as well unbalanced and
I think there are problem with that to
be currently is that there are a lot of
numbers out there there's actually not
that much space percentage-wise between
the numbers in terms of how much
fugitive mandate escapes and then I
think a supply chain the problem is that
there's that sort of uncertainty behind
Falls bringing around the number that
have to be that in fact true for gaseous
and in today's context to be better than
identical in terms of electricity
generation as a change driver so that's
a really super important amiracle
question anyone out there
that pieces are not in place don't know
the answer to that question it's often
hard to proceed you know with shale gas
development the confidence that this is
gonna be good for climbing a certain
reason they think that it's no good
question you over to talk about whether
in fact it's a bridge to a low-carbon
future is that gas just in the way that
it acts out a coal from an electricity
production in a country with us
especially at a current very very low
prices
it also backs out some your goals and
some nuclear's and things that actually
have lower her into in society and their
gas and so that's true even in bottles
and keep you safe in arc with in other
places that's true even if international
climate policy in place that has some
kind of price on carbon
okay so there's always going to be the
sort of substitution the times not just
some of the bad stuff but also other
things and then finally look at prices
which are great anybody when it
communions winter last winter we have
very low heating bills relative to the
winter supplier and that's in part
because it is quite warm here but it's
also Americans of shield house so as Jen
mentioned this is already certainly
affected people still illegals and
pretentiousness commercial industrial
all kinds of manufacturing has really
benefited from these low prices but when
you have
maybe have lower electricity prices for
electricity prices increase demand and
so you have some increased emissions
associated faculty behind compact as
well and so when you have your reasoning
together the methane question the
increased consumption from little prices
could have some time alone with this
prices stay low
is sort of hard to say but nobody's
really seriously talking about prices
above $5 the gas before the fire so low
for the foreseeable future
and also the vacuum is less or lower
carbon energy sources this question
whether it's really to low carbon
teachers that these tell us an
incredible question second if you're
talking about being enriched to a
cleaner local air pollution future and I
think unquestionably into these clearer
we're not necessarily with respect to
the wind or solar array certainly
perspective to the coal which is a
significant chunk still serving in many
states and certainly in developing
countries of the Hoover electricity
generation so concerned mostly got
locally revolution and I think the
jury's not in our future and then
finally the other key factors of course
the other local environmental impacts
which we've mentioned in this discussion
as well so we're not looking just about
in communities that are there we don't
have to scale so again there's a lot of
time talking about this concentrated one
question is it a British I think it's a
highlight think of the i-10 from
Jacksonville Florida Santa Monica
California
natural gas is a highway to the future
and yes a cleaner more sustainable
future for the number of the following
reasons first of all let me just say
you've ever been to a prep site it's
dirty
built your noisy smoky dusty when you
did 15 or more compression trucks
generating 15,000 horsepower each to
force sand water and chemicals down home
in order to bring the province
open up the molecules for movement under
a mile all over the surface of the earth
too much in the grill site you know that
you are putting a lot of energy into
that earth into that well and witnessing
it is about as pleasurable as witnessing
the source of your hamburgers chicken
wings or baby it's not pleasant but we
like to give that because the effect is
low-cost energy to keep us warm keep us
cool and really to provide economic
value creation and economic security
across many sectors of the economy let
me suggest and propose voter on board of
directors of hunting PLC PLC you'll see
that we are an equipment supplier to the
drilling industry and we make the
tubulars to go down the well we acquired
within the past 15 months the company
that creates the frack charges itself
these explosives so I'm very closely
associated with what that was long and I
can tell you that from my prior
experience as president of Shell up to
an including the current court
experience I would submit that there is
more engineering more risk abatement
more time human capital human ingenuity
that goes into a frack job or a drilling
of a website then goes into heart
surgery it is an incredible process with
the best that man can know about what to
do penetrate that earth and to do it in
a way that is sustainable and repeatable
and meets the criteria of most
I know wishes do no harm do no harm to
people do no harm to the environment and
be able to maintain your license to
operate in the public domain there are
exceptions and I'm more than happy to
discuss the exceptions not the least of
which was the environmental and human
disaster in the Gulf of Mexico on the
Deepwater Horizon debacle
given the technology and given the
opportunity to continue this process and
learning that encouraged as the process
continues there is actually never under
way friend of mine Hartman Cohen of the
clean air task force from Boston
currently working with the largest
companies to create a voluntary set of
gold standards which the energy
companies will sign for which does the
kinds of things that need to be done if
this is to be a long-standing industrial
effort in this country the things that
need to be done to tighten the wells
tighten the cases tighten the cement
jobs take an approach to water
management with respect to containment
and treatment as is the case of a new
nanotechnology product developed at Rice
University in Houston in which you can
take the frack water out of the well
with all the pollutants that come with
it
everything from the benzene to the nasty
stuff and it isn't
tonight and after treating the product
the water in this water containment
system all the water also with
can be made against the engineering we
know that we can do
the
there were all sorts of people even
because predicted the new 12% decline
next year in window
the quest of the effect would be
availability of cheap natural gas so
that's all three which is why a long
term analyses that have been done that
show that even if you somehow converted
the whole planet - gasps we would end up
with hopeless either change the
International Energy Agency Randall date
holding a golden age of gases and
peridot in May and the report said that
if you were able to keep cold oil
production by 2020 and with us all on
the gas which is a rapid pace you would
end up with a 660 person per million co2
the world and one degrees already melted
the planet and if by the way only to
have a take issue this agrees big goal
is to do no harm to the environment is
all that they have failed to meet the
melting Arctic being one of the 30% more
acid being another the 5% more moisture
atmosphere because of the warm air
that's what we're going to have much
much much more if we instead of pursuing
the rules pursue this easy of course
instead and for of course even aside
from all the data about carbon and and
none of this even takes into account
fact we don't know yet whether or not we
need the methane consequences will make
it even worse than coal in the long run
it depends entirely on what beat these
brakes are they're kind of it at this
point of Terror dueling studies Cornell
one saying be 2% 1% the only actual
science of fractal and Colorado a
vintage rate there's 4% I eat enough to
make it or worse technology than qual
inch were tracking crap gasps Mason
climate crisis at best in current terms
of teaching get better and we're long
past the point for baby steps question
anyway in fact if they keep us tiring
down
there's nothing
well as we promised we've got quite a
range of experience and points of view
here what I'm going to do now for the
second round is take some of the
questions that students have helped put
together and post them to each of the
panelists and then get panelists an
opportunity to to comment on the answers
that have been given Jim I'm going to
ask this lady and a fair question to
scientists but it picked up on a part of
what Bill was talking about about
dueling studies and the fact that
there's an awful lot that's unknown from
a scientific point of view and as a
scientist Jim you know lots of
scientists a policy never makers never
listen to me you know possibly Kirk even
said hey you know based on what we know
but we don't know what would you do if
you were a policymaker would you put a
moratorium on fracking would you
continue and watch which the
recommendation of that rather than offer
recommendations I'm going to tell you
what I think will happen
there are 22 states where shale gas
development is occurring in the Rockies
the Northeast and even in California I
think that it's unlikely that we're
going to see any statewide moratoriums
like is going on in the state of New
York I also think that in several months
New York will partially lift that
moratorium
they'll mention that there were there
are several bands and moratorium that
are going on at the local level and one
of those bands could hold up against
state authority remains to be seen so I
pretty convinced that that shale gas
development has a lot of support from
our current administration has support
within the states it will proceed now in
terms of research looking at its impact
not surprisingly research labs and
research will continue to be reactive it
will respond to emerging problems that's
not how I would like to do it or how
many of you
like to do but but I think that that
that that's the immediate future
moreover outlook that shale gas
development is way out of head of
research on environmental impacts and
that landscape doesn't look any better
going forward there's far too little
money going in to looking at
environmental impacts health impacts
Obama's administration proposed
significant budget for that that was cut
states Pennsylvania proposed significant
budget to look at environmental health
impacts that was cut and to me that's
that's the scary part with any of our
other panelists like to comment on
the idea that the idea that you might
want to wait and find out what's going
on before you about too far seems to me
the absolute commonplace especially
since we need to clear carbon and
metadata makes it clear that there's no
great reason to be doing this but I
think the contest here the reason that
it's very hard is because the fossil
fuel industry is huge resources into
making sure that there are fans and
thanks all the huge sums of money and
and and it was only the people of New
York rising up to try and stop it
there's the rest of it so far it's one
of these classic fights between money
and people and it's something it's not
ok to say well it's inevitable it's
going to happen that's not an argument
that some that's just concession to
power which we've had too much of in
this country on too many issues for - on
movements and it is possible to
challenge we may not win this Keystone
fight in the long run but for a year
anyway that we've managed to so far stop
the pipeline to the tar sands of Canada
if you come tonight to the political
union we're going to be talking about
the launch of this big nationwide
campaign
divestment from places like Yale all
over the country we've gotta stand up to
these cows in fracking there's one good
place to do it because people all over
the place can I respond quickly in that
truck I think it's a simplification to
call this big industry versus the
populace a recent poll was just released
by Quinnipiac they said the plurality of
upstate New Yorkers where shale gas
development is going to occur favor show
my next question was going to be to
Sheila to talk a little bit about while
many national studies say that the US
economy as a whole will benefit from
access to shale gas there's lots of
debate about whether that's true at the
local level so building on Jim's
question about or the attitudes of
upstaging workers Witter what are you
seeing in your economic work about the
constant benefits to local communities
where shale gas go that's happening so
this is again a key question so the work
that the browser granted is a project
going on
she has many different parts that is
thought very much lasagna environmental
risks that she has so we're thinking
about that global of the national
context but as I promised we also see
very much that benefit aside that's not
subject at this particular project or
peoples of the Pacific lately but I
think you know first when I always used
to tell my students is that I was I
don't like sort of said well here the
genomic impacts and here the
department's in fact if I meant Olympics
RF any economic impacts they have
benefits data cost many that can be
monetized and weighed against each each
other in a trade-off sense just like the
journalist was talking about at the very
beginning and when you know we can't
really do that on the environmental cost
side yet we just can't there just isn't
enough evidence that there may not be
for quite a long time it's what we're
doing data analysis but we're looking
backward or learning from what's
happened before rest as Jim mentioned
we're sort of playing catch-up in a
sense and maybe there's some sense in
which this is going to unfold across the
country and one state will learn from
another so there's a little bit of that
as well and so that's
but in general we just we just don't
know chemically the best area to
quantify or monetize some of those heart
attacks
yeah but if we could you know it might
actually for now maybe certainly there
are very very large benefits at the
national scale okay just those low
prices you know prices for natural gas
around you know fitness to an eighth and
what people were thinking they'd be you
know at this point in certainly looking
forward in the country anticipated being
a significant importer of natural gas
from countries like Russia Venezuela
Iran and so there are certainly these
very big benefits that come from the
lower prices the increased consumption
letting you because consumers are
accustomed increases profits for
producers and that make this sort of
rising tide and as the potential at
least potential at least in all those so
then the question is any what is the
cost side look like and we're not
talking about an option cause you have
to assume that it was absolutely blown
off to be generating the kind of supply
that we've seen today but the external
possible ones that are the harder ones
to quantify so even in the national
levels it's hard to say it's just that
it even a Canada sort of
to those to those very big benefits
particularly during times of recession
so then the second important question
becomes what about is distributional
questions right what about the ten
tending to be rural areas in states all
over the country that were allowed the
extraction is taking place although
there are exceptions to that Fort Worth
Texas with their suburban areas where
there's significant expansion as well
how does that I'm here at how people are
feeling the cities and in fact a lot of
composition in New York has to do with
worry over impacts of service water
supply as much of what's driving I think
New York City's system into the pipeline
ready to be bleeding people that are
concerned about the attacks in the
Delaware River Basin so those
distributional impacts our urban I think
driving a lot of this discussion and I
and I had also read the that of the the
poll that Jim was talking about that a
narrow morality to New Yorkers support
shale gas development I think there are
some studies that have been done about
local economic impacts okay so you can
imagine you're in this community you're
in one or two groups of people you know
I'm a release holder or you're not are
you so it's you know sold your land or
the race to the minerals underneath your
land to a or not if you have you are in
many cases receiving some significant
financial compensation for that if you
have that then you're not so that maybe
you want to may to think about the sort
of winners or losers at the local level
but there's also a regional economic
development
say you've got all of this sort of
classic boomtown impact you know if
anyone has been a time they're good a
city like blimps where Pennsylvania on
the Little League World Series not that
it wasn't obviously a town in many ways
but now it's really women it's kind of
amazing you're going to pay for and an
opportunity to state that your network
are because there's just no space where
people everywhere the amount of you not
attempt to is huge and there are
unquestionably benefits to that as well
so a lot of studies that have been done
at that regional level have focused on
this you know what it really is a short
to medium run impact of those low
benefits and try to quantify those and
the hard thing is an economic
perspective is that it's it's kind of
tough to quantify those particularly the
employment impacts so those are two big
numbers that get thrown around those
studies that are done you know by the
state of New York State and Pennsylvania
interest groups both sides often focus
on this job especially we can see why
they had done that they've done that
high unemployment it's a big focus on
the national scene so it's thought to be
and works of a chip in the discussion
but the truth is that economics actually
not that many academic economists that
work on this question of job creation
and that's because labor is mobile the
job created in one place is all moving
somebody and that seen things out of it
or sector or later from one place to
another and then you know there are
benefits if you're talking about County
and town be you know 1018 attract a lot
more development because it's got some
fracking going on but that might mean
you get some potential cost to town bees
it's drawn those folks there so
qualifying this those labor impacts
actually is really tricky it has to be
done very well it's not something
anybody even talking about certainly on
the national scale we were a full
employment or employment that say less
than 5% in this country it is something
we're talking about because we're in
that situation and it's important factor
but I haven't seen one study diamond out
of national level or regional level that
I would say is a really good study that
is as careful as it should begin trying
to quantify this impacts on our planet
so I just approach those studies with
skepticism and that's not to say that
there aren't important local we do need
to knock impacts but I be careful in
that the employment person which is
often would be number and then finally I
would say that you know these regions
have been through this before some of
them okay
is a great case because we've had oil in
Pennsylvania we got a call and hit
something and still do a neat innocent
part and some there's also some of the
beauties particularly Southwest we're
gonna have shale gas and so there is
actually a boom-bust cycle to this sort
of reduce dependence on resource
extraction for to drop the local economy
and there are recent managing that there
are ways of trying to serve smooth that
over time and our basic trying to manage
the downside I'm not sure that I would
say any thoughts in place in fact in
Pennsylvania until recently it was one
of only four states out of 32 with some
show hasn't had a bit of severance tax
you know there's no severance tax an
impact fee and they have formula by Oh
Jerry it's treating that two
municipalities in two counties and so on
but you know what we need is sort of a
system in place that's going to sort of
smooth out that Loomis cycle over time
and means something right once the the
decline occurs on those wells are back
and near the bottom and we don't see the
extraction happening generating those
benefits locally when it happens since I
think that's also an important question
and again neither of those none of these
important questions about regional
impacts should attract from the fact
that there are a significant national
benefits to this whole process is just
the distributional questions that we
cover and pull of New York State voters
asked just a question that Jim was asked
a minute ago to be waiting for studies
to be completed before opening the state
to fracking 72%
your honors including sixty-six percent
across the shale belt think you'd be a
good idea to wait until we've done the
work just a difference
Jim or John anything to this so John let
me go back to the standards point that
you mentioned in your introductory
remarks you talked about folks working
on voluntary standards that the HP might
sign may be a two-part question one many
people would say why voluntary why not
regulatory standards and so how do you
see those two comparing and then related
to that whether it's voluntary or
regulatory you know what are the key
features of standards for this industry
what should they look like and where she
adopted I never try to convince somebody
who's 1894 evident they should be
providing her because that's I've been
burning a Muslim to Christianity or
Judaism unlikely to occur and I say that
quite seriously but in the backdrop of
the standards let's remember that every
day 250 million cars or on the highways
of America every home in America needs
electricity so there's two kinds of
energy use in this country one is
electrons and the other is
when it comes to standards there are
regulatory agencies then go through the
governance process of establishing rules
regulations where companies have to
apply for licences and in order to get
the licenses they have to guarantee
demonstrated standards and rules the
standards and the rules are established
in a democratic fashion through public
hearings through best known science
through best known regulatory processes
and there is follow-up to make sure that
those standards are being followed but
as we all know we're a route we're a
nation that is ruled by law why do we
have so many prisoners in prisons they
break the law they don't follow the
rules unfortunately there are some
actors in the industry that break the
rules they don't follow the rules they'd
rather cut corners save a buck or save a
lot more than a buck and they help
destroy the image of an industry that is
predicated on the license to operate
which is a public gift and and and to
suggest that the oil companies are out
to control society is simply a made-up
statement because it's society which
demands energy and the oil companies are
the facilitators of getting the energy
to those who demand it and it has been
always thus in in my opinion but let's
as a society hold people to standards
the reason there are voluntary standards
is there are companies who feel that the
regulations don't go far enough but when
the democratic process creates those
regulations the argument around cost the
argument around ability to operate not
license to operate but ability to
operate and so there is a back-and-forth
a given a take ultimately it's the
government official that sets the
regulations the source of much of that
information as to setting the regular
patience comes from the industry
government itself does not grow the
talent base that knows enough about the
science or the industrial processes to
know how to set the regulations and the
standards there are human beings who
learn and have a lot of knowledge but
not enough knowledge there are companies
like my former company Exxon Chevron
ConocoPhillips and others who I'm happy
to name because I'm proud of their
willingness and their ability to sign up
for tougher standards because from a
competitive standpoint they would rather
weed out those who aren't willing to
meet the standards deny them the license
to operate but in a free society those
companies still have a voice and they
can connect with elected officials just
like anybody else they can connect with
regulators just like anybody else and in
the given to take of the process the
regulator's don't always set the golden
standard secretary Salazar since he's
been in office has taught in in
Department of Interior has talked about
establishing the golden standard for
offshore drilling the industry has
testified in favor of those standards
and is complying with those standards in
the Deepwater Gulf of Mexico since the
horrible incident and so I'm a big
believer that standards mandatory are
oftentimes not the highest just like
student testing there could be a lot
higher standard in student testing that
many students wouldn't make the grade so
at some point you make a judgment as to
what the standard should be that's the
regulatory effect but those companies
who have the capability the technology
and the willingness to go further do
indeed go further so their cement job is
a little tighter the threading that they
demand on the tubulars that go
underground is more rigid more more and
more in their control the down-well
fracking process the materials the
chemicals used in the fracking itself
many of the companies are moving to
through biochemical research are moving
to bio lubricants made from biomass
which really do not have the hard
full effects of some of the other
chemical potions that that have been put
down because they're not natural they're
they're refined and so there are these
kinds of things that happen and it
really is in the name of sustained
operations to maintain that license to
operate the notion that we've set
standards on energy use in this country
through an open democratic process where
everyone had the same stake is incorrect
the biggest contributors year after year
to our political process including if
you read the New York Times last Friday
to this year's political process are the
fossil fuel industry by a large margin
in the case of fracking far from setting
things by a some kind of open process
where we looked at the best standards of
things it's every journalist who's ever
written about it has told the story of
how Dick Cheney pretty much in under
cover of darkness rammed through what's
known as the Halliburton rule that
exempts the fracking industry from the
Safe Drinking Water Act for the most
part we have no idea what chemicals put
a people are putting down wells because
they don't have to tell us
that's what in the real world how this
happens the question the sort of idea
that society demands energy and the
energy industry is just there to convey
it misses that essential reality society
demands energy but society would be just
as happy perhaps happier if it came from
things like the wind and the Sun the
people who wouldn't be happier are the
exons and the shells and the Chevron's
because they're making more money than
any companies in the history of money
selling hydrocarbons right at the moment
and the idea that one would be anti
hydrocarbon or pro hydrocarbon and that
it's sort of like being Christian or
Muslim is strikes me as a strange
analogy hydrocarbons have been very
useful in the past and now from
everything that our scientists tell us
including
of the great physicists and chemists
here at Yale we know that they are
composing a risk to the planet greater
than any risk the planet has ever
undergone before it's not a negotiation
between Christians and Muslims or
Democrats and Republicans or you know
some other kind of flavors of things
it's a negotiation at this point between
human beings on the one hand and physics
on the other okay and physics is not Pro
hydrocarbon it's just gonna do what its
gonna do with the amount of carbon that
we put up in the atmosphere and you know
given the pictures that come back from
the Arctic this year given the scenes
across the Midwest of what the drought
looked like given what happens if you
stick a pH strip in the ocean these days
it's pretty clear what side physics at
this point is on I think with a question
pretty obviously shale gas hydro
fracking is not your bridge to a clean
energy future can you talk a little bit
about what you see as the transformative
leap that needs to be taken you know and
how do we best get there in the current
political and economic climate and given
the young environmental leaders in the
room what's most important for them to
do to help make that happen the first
most important transformative technology
is incredible push toward conservation
and efficiency which we're capable of
making very very large gains with it
gets harder the more cheap energy we
have around second thing is that
renewables are now you know 20 years ago
we talked about renewables with our
fingers crossed and because they weren't
quite ready for prime time but that's
not the case anymore there were days
last month when Germany the one large
country that's taken seriously this
problem generated more than half the
power that it used from solar panels
within its borders that to me says that
the problem we face is not technological
it's a question of political will and
the engineers are getting but just for
luck just are getting better and better
at them
for where I'm sorry they be engineers
events from the other rooms the
engineers are getting better and better
at dealing with the problems that used
to plague us things like intermittency
that made it more difficult there was a
study yesterday that came out
demonstrating that you could with a
hundred and forty-four thousand wind
turbines up and down the East Coast
offshore and generate all the
electricity that the East Coast used you
wouldn't have to do it all by wind but
it made it clear that you could it does
not come for free it comes at a cost but
the cost is definitely less than the
cost of dealing with a planet heating
out of control and that's important to
remember is the option always on the
other side here so I mean I you know as
to how we're gonna get here in our
current political climate there's only I
mean we may not you know the power of
the fossil fuel industry is enormous
they have all the money so if we're
gonna do anything about it we need to
find other currencies in which to work I
would submit those are most likely to be
the currencies of movement passion
spirit creativity sometimes like Gus
Speth you might need to spend your body
you know in the course of this um but
that's what movements are like and one
really hopes that one will arise here in
New Haven in the course of the next
month's and that you guys will
demonstrate what that other approach to
political power looks like you're not
gonna have the money to match the exons
and the shells but you may have other
things that you can bring to the table
speaking for my former company which I
must do under these circumstances shell
makes no political contributions at all
has not and as it is a matter of global
policy the US Chamber of Commerce I
don't know what I was there yes it is
and the US Chamber Commerce has been the
biggest front group for the fossil fuel
industry it was the biggest donor in the
last election cycle and it filed a brief
with the EPA two years ago saying that
we didn't need to worry about climate
change because if by some mister
all the scientists turned out to be
right and the plan had heated up it
would be okay human beings would adapt
their behavior and physiology in order
to deal with the warmer planet it's akin
to what the CEO of Exxon said this
summer before the Council on Foreign
Relations he said true global warming's
real but it's an engineering problem
with engineering solutions someone asked
him what those might be he said well if
we need to move our crop production
areas by which I believe he meant farms
um if we need to move if we need to move
our crop production areas we will this
is the example of the kind of fantasy
that reigns within the fossil feeders
despite the fact that they're quickly
melting the taiga forest
you can't just when it gets too hot to
grow corn and aiya the way it did this
summer move the whole operation up to
the you know up onto the tundra there's
not Saul there to do it we you know it's
time to start taking real let me correct
a minute let me correct a myth mmm
that the oil industry is homogeneous and
is in unanimous voice I found Rex
Tillerson speech at the Council on
Foreign Relations to be a
backward-looking self-serving Exxon
shareholder speech that did not speak
for the industry it spoke for Exxon
Mobil I'm on the public record many many
times over and over even as president of
Shell that there should be no private
money in campaign financing campaign
financing should be public money only
because it is true the abusive power of
money in campaign financing creates
unfortunate outcomes and I consider it
destructive to the democratic principles
on which the country was founded I may
be a rarity in the industry that says
that
and but in the course in the course of
these discussions I think it's important
to note that there are differences of
opinion within the energy industry and
no one speaks for the energy industry
each company speaks for itself in that
case would be a very good idea to get
Shell and others out of the Chamber of
Commerce and out of the American
Petroleum Institute which have been the
sort of pass-throughs by which people
have supported the petha lobbying
heavily and supported candidates for for
office well here you if you step out
then you can't influence the outcome you
have to be a part of it to influence the
outcome in the case of the API for
example most of what the American
Petroleum Institute does is set
industry-wide standards which apply to
the whole world ultimately and to have
your voice at the table to set those
standards is a very important part of
membership the same with the Chamber of
Commerce when I sit with Tom Donohue or
sat with Tom Donohue is see as president
of Shell to tell him my view on
cap-and-trade having been one of the
founders of the United States Climate
Action Partnership having worked for
years to create a cap and trade policy
for this country only to have the
framework created by the u.s. c.a.p
which consisted of a large number of
companies NGOs and worked in voluntary
fashion to create a framework for
Congress in the 210th Congress having
said to Ed Markey having said to mr.
Waxman don't rush this if you rush this
you'll kill it
the country's not ready this needs time
this needs seasoning this needs to be
baked in the oven and how many and so
but they rushed they rushed they got the
house to pass it I said to Markey
shortly after the house passed it dead
on arrival in the Senate which it was
now we have a presidential campaign
several years later how much are we
hearing about cap-and-trade absolutely
nothing by rushing things in this
democracy we go backwards we have to
change incrementally we have to change
carefully we have to change in a way the
society can adapt and adjust to it
or we go backwards stay on this theme
but I want to give each of John and Bill
a chance to talk about a question
if you could so we've seen this
discourse happening in front of us you
know is it about hydro car anti
hydrocarbons or for hydrocarbons or is
it about the fossil fuel industry being
in charge or not being in charge if each
of you could change the nature of the
dialogue if you will between the energy
community and the environmental
community or however you want to frame
it you know how would you change it I
know John you've spent a lot of time
going around the country talking to
people about it bill you've had a recent
article in Rolling Stone saying
basically you know the fossil fuel
industry pretty much should be written
off as a political force to talk a
little bit about what you would if you
made a step steps forward what would be
the most important steps do you think
moving forward on this I start with the
framework to try to help people
understand the the incredible size and
and and materiality of the energy system
and given its history and given where we
are I try to start with the framework of
let's talk in a dialogue that talks
about short term medium term and long
term where short term is zero to 10
years because in energy space nothing
really happens in in in in less than 10
years it takes time medium term 10 to 25
long term 25 to 50 once you get people
talking in terms of the three sections
of what do you do now what do you do
later what do you do over time I think
we can create a carbon free energy
system but we can't get there by rushing
it in the in in the course of a short
period of time it won't happen we don't
have the technology you know we don't we
are not going to build you know the
million or more wind turbines it would
take in this country to make a material
impact on the energy system the public
won't allow it
people don't like the the I love wind
turbines I think they're an art form
when you see them all together turning
in synchronicity or in synchrony but a
lot of people hate them especially
people that have them on their ranches
they don't like what happens they don't
like to see it built the land gets torn
up I've been there I had a win
business when I was at Shell I had the
you know the hateful comments from the
ranchers get off my property and and so
we did we just went to the next property
but but the key point here is break it
into time spans that people can get
their heads around in a way in which
work real work can be done the second
thing I would say is this is not the oil
companies versus society this is public
policy fed by special interest money
versus the needs of society in which
society doesn't really know enough yet
to have a point of view that is informed
you're fortunate because you have lots
of information the people I generally
talk to are from church sanctuary
podiums or from high school stages or
other grassroots engagements where
people don't know and when you don't
know what you don't know you don't know
where you're going and so grassroots
education becomes fundamental not
ideological education but real education
about what it takes to know what you
need to know if you're going to be a
voter and a citizen and and so I think
that we need the public policy
leadership of a short medium long term
plan which we have been unable to
achieve in the modern age Rolling Stone
article you called fossil fuel industry
public enemy number one how would you
see this in my short term scenario I
think maybe the very first thing I do
would be to have if I was able to
influence things powerfully would be to
have the fossil fuel industry stop
exploring for new hydrocarbons they
already have at that point of that
Rolling Stone piece with these set of UK
financial analysts who determined that
the fossil fuel industry already had
five times as much hydrocarbons in their
reserves as it would take to move us
past the two degree mark that the
world's governments have agreed on is
the sort of red line in fact it's much
too higher red line one-degree melts the
Arctic so to degree but I would stop
exploring for new high
carbons for instance where I shall I
would not be as they have in the last
six weeks been leading the rush into the
Arctic to begin drilling drilling made
possible only because they've melted the
Arctic over the last forty years but
it's shell that's up there finding a why
Exxon spends a hundred million dollars a
day looking for new hydrocarbon fracking
is a perfect example of this kind of
work the problem with the kind of short
medium long term all this sort of thing
is we're running out of time it's
tiresome force me to say though I take
this at least the tiniest bit of
satisfaction in saying it that having
written the first book about all this
twenty five years ago if you'd listened
to me then you know we'd be we would
have been able to do some of these
things at a slightly different time
scale here's the numbers if we're gonna
stay below that two degrees okay at the
moment that that will we have an
allotment of about 565 gigatons worth of
carbon left to burn we're currently
burning about 31 Giga tons worth a year
and it's increasing about three percent
a year do the math on your iPhone we're
sixteen years away from going past the
line that even the most conservative
governments on earth United Arab
Emirates China even the US have signed
on to as the kind of bottom red line
this is not about our convenience about
what would be nice and easy for society
about a gentle and soft landing for the
fossil fuel industry and its
shareholders it's about trying to keep
from breaking the planet which is what
we're currently doing you've been doing
some research on aspects of this debate
that we've been having surveys of
experts and their perceptions of for
their findings on the risks of shale gas
and also of the general public and their
perceptions of the risks can you tell us
about how those perceptions and
impressions compare and if they are
pretty disconnected what kinds of
changes are what kinds of programs going
forward do you think would make the most
sense yeah so what price referring to
you there are as part of this major
project at rff there are two different
surveys one of which is done
and in and being analyzed and there's a
report a draft report in place and that
is an attempt to kind of look forward so
as I said when we're working with
observational data trying to understand
you know what some of the environmental
risks are from this activity we have to
look backward we have to say okay well
let's see you know how shale gas
development you know looked in
Pennsylvania over the last few years and
what have been the impacts on water
quality but things change quickly and so
while that's a really important exercise
and one can learn from that exercise
what we wanted to do when we started the
project was to say well the literature
is pretty thin I mean there's a very
there's a huge literature on the sort of
petroleum engineering sense of you know
how to get gas out of these wells
cost-effectively you know what a
productive well looks like what the
dwell design looks like but a really
really thin literature on what the
potential risks might be and so we
thought well one thing that one could do
in addition to just waiting right for
the sort of incremental contributions of
science in the way that that works would
be to look at those contributions but
also to do a survey of folks that are
working kind of on the frontlines in
this field in academics and industry in
government and in NGOs and get a sense
for what if there's some sort of some
degree of consensus that we can find
over what some of the highest priority
impacts are our potential impacts I
should say are and so we sort of set up
a system whereby we developed a set of
what we were calling priority impact
pathways going all the way from a sort
of piece of the shale gas development
process to some you know end points so
for example you have fracturing and
completion of a well and one of the
activities associated with that is truck
traffic and truck traffic generates
local air pollutants and that has
impacts on human health and so on so
there's all these different pathways and
it turned out we came up with about 264
of those and that formed the basis of
this expert survey and what we had
people do is had them go through and
choose you know which ones of these this
whole set given your expertise given
your training got lots of information
about that for each respondent are what
you would call sort of high priority and
then we're able to look across those
groups and see you know kind of how they
compare and try and find some you know
kind of red lines underneath particular
potential impacts so that would point
the way forward for either more
search or some voluntary action on the
part of industry or some some regulatory
action or some combination of all three
of those and the interesting thing so I
think it's very easy to feel when you're
hearing debates on a panel like this
that you know things are just so
polarized in a question like the climate
question or something else that it's
really hard to see that there's a middle
ground or even if there was whether
you'd be interested in it at all I think
I'm more of an incrementalist than bill
and so I'm happy to you know sort of be
searching for that middle ground and I'm
hopeful that the middle ground will be a
place where we find some some net
benefits even including environmental
impacts and the nice thing is that this
in this survey if you look at these
results if we take the top 20 of all
those pathways that each respondent
identified and we compare them across
groups twelve of those pathways are in
common across all the four groups that
includes NGOs and Industry which tend
we'd sort of tend to think about as
representing the sort of polar opposite
views on these questions and it's really
interesting stuff so you take the you
know those twelve that are held in
common there's some consensus there
seven of those are impacts to surface
water two are to ground water to art of
air quality but they're both about
methane not about local air pollutants
and then the final one is about habitat
fragmentation from infrastructure well
pads roads pipelines and so on and so
for us right so my perspective is let's
sort of find that you know are there
some areas of consensus where we can get
a sense and they may be wrong right this
is again the nature of this kind of
exercise is that in ten years we could
say boy we really thought that this
surface water thing was going to be a
problem but it turns out you know it's
something we didn't know about so
there's no way to know right for sure
whether these are the right things but
it can help sort of point us in the
right direction so I think one positive
thing from that aspect of our work has
been thinking well you know there's
actually more consensus than you might
think where it breaks down is when you
ask people well what should we do about
this and so then there we see you know
if we ask people should it be you know
sort of industry that takes primary
responsibility for addressing this
particular pathway or should it be
primarily government regulation or some
combination of the two there's actually
a surprising number of people in all
four of the groups that say some
combination but you know as you might
expect that you know there's a pretty
strong feeling in industry that industry
should take the lead on average there's
a pretty strong feeling one
josè that government should take the
lead and then the other groups fall in
between and I take to heart dongs
earlier comment about the heterogeneity
within industry just as one example of
that i was i mean i've given briefs on
this work to epa and I've given briefs
on this work to api and i did the one to
api over the web and on the phone and by
accident a group of industry folks in a
boardroom and i want to say which which
operator or which major firm left their
kind of connection on so i was hearing
the discussion and i had to tell them
not you know to switch it off because
everybody was hearing the discussion but
as I went through the this divided about
who should take the lead obviously there
were that actually there was a
reasonably significant amount of
Industry response that said either
government should take the lead or that
there should be shared responsibility
and you could hear everybody at this
table saying who would have said that
like well I would do why would you say
anything but industry should take the
lead right but there of course people on
the phone who were respondents to the
survey that said in fact that government
should take the lead so there is a lot
of heterogeneity and again I find that
to be sort of a source of hope and then
this other survey that we're that we're
doing that's it's basically a survey of
individuals
so just households in Pennsylvania and
in Texas where we're asking people to
make as economists tend to do in their
surveys explicit trade offs between you
know what they might be willing to pay
in increased energy bills for example
for reductions and specific types of
risks associated with shale gas
development okay so we give them a
careful description of what some of
those risks might be we actually can
change the language and we're doing some
of that we sort of express it in the API
style language and in geo style language
and what we are hoping is a neutral
stylus or rff style language and we can
see whether that shifts people's
perceptions of risk whether it shifts
their willingness to pay unfortunately
the results of that are not back in yet
we have some you know interesting stuff
that's happening in focus groups but I
can't say ex ante yet what the
comparison will be but we certainly are
interested in doing that to see how well
individual or sort of household
perceptions of risk match up with with
those of experts any comments from any
other members of the panel on this sort
of perception issue Jim let me go back
to something you said earlier
about there's not enough research
there's not enough funding for research
in this area a common complaint amongst
faculty so let's assume that you
actually had lots of money and you look
across the potential impacts from water
supplies air quality rural lands impacts
community impacts and whatnot you know
which of those impacts would you focus
on sort of as highest priority and and
what would you do and what would you be
looking for to help you figure out where
to go forward from here
generally speaking would what's missing
her measurements if you look across air
impacts land impacts water quality
impacts there's just a dearth dearth of
measurements so for example if you would
take water there there there's an
assumption that's made that when wells
are hydraulically fraktur too deep
there's not enough water injected the
overlying rock is too impermeable for
that water to rise up and contaminate
drinking water supplies that's an
assumption a lot of people believe it I
believe it it's just my opinion and so
what we have is a lot of expert opinions
without ever running the experiment so
that might be one place where you would
begin to look another concern related to
water quality is is methane
contamination it's all seen about it
you've seen it in gas land people
lighting their taps on fire that better
eyes is from por que si por el
construction and so industry and
regulatory agencies have responded and
they've made well construction they
they've raised the standards so the
question is well are those standards
good enough well you would run an
experiment and say well let's let's take
a look at these new casing methods and
see if they were that they really do
protect aquifers on the air quality side
there's concerns about greenhouse gas
emissions follow organic carbon
and methane release is is my fault
panelists have suggested before there's
a lot of debate here and once again
what's missing are measurements and and
EPA is getting in on this they will
require methods or measurements of
greenhouse gas emissions from from these
sites soon and that in and that's a step
forward what Jim was getting at at the
end there is exactly right the thing
that we if you wanted to know one thing
it would be what methane release rates
are into the atmosphere I think I mean
no one hears argued with my basic
contention that even in carbon terms you
end up with three-and-a-half Celsius
degree warmer world if you convert it to
gas that you end up at 660 parts per
million so that's bad even if you go
this course but there's a chance that
we're making this much much worse by
adding a lot of methane to the
atmosphere if those 4% leak rates that
prevailed in Colorado actually prevail
across the industry then then we're just
adding greenhouse gases at a terrific
rate to the atmosphere annoyingness so
that would be the thing that if you you
know if there were some graduate
students looking for something to work
on that's the thing I'd like the most to
know about right away because it's kind
of an emergency question and it's also a
relatively easy one to fix methane
emissions from gas wells occur during
the flowback period before the well
after it's completed it's hooked up to
the natural gas lines and and there are
such a thing as green completions that
collect that gas that's released before
that hookup but there is a question that
reduces methane emissions how much
another big contributor to air quality
impairment is just the sheer number of
diesel engines involved in shale gas
extraction to run pumps to run
compressor stations
and and they're there ways to improve
that shift for example from diesel
engines to compressed natural gas so
there are ways around it or at least
ways to mitigate John do you have any
areas that you think are particularly
worthy of further research well III
think that I would switch gears in terms
of that research I think that we need to
make progress in as I said earlier
tightening the wells and applying new
forms of technology to make things ever
more evermore precise in in a natural
gas area but where we need research and
where we need to apply that research is
in what I believe will be the
alternative energy sources of the future
today's solar is little better than
commercial junk with all due respect to
those who make it it simply is not
sufficiently efficient to ever take and
grab at an affordable level the needs of
society we have to put a lot of time and
energy into nanotechnology research to
create the material that has yet to be
created that will create the
efficiencies needed and by efficiencies
needed I'm talking north of 40%
efficiencies on a sustained basis
because not only of the cost benefit
reality competing against other sources
but we have one chance in a generation
to lead the world and if we don't agree
on a way forward in this society with
only 5% of the world's population the
rest of the world is going to just go
whatever do whatever they do
there is no leadership out there Europe
with all due respect can't afford what
they're trying to do and they're about
to go belly up they're officially
technically bankrupt they just haven't
admitted it yet in terms of their
deficit financing we're headed that path
down that pathway unfortunately as well
but we have the best technology in the
world the best innovative minds the best
universities in the world bar none no
one argues with that that I've ever
heard that says we can't do what we need
to do from a research and development
so I'm a big believer in solar but only
if we can crack the code with
nanotechnology I'm a big believer in
biofuels but we haven't cracked the code
in biochemistry yet to get to process
solutions to create the kind of scale we
would need to create to really
substitute for oil natural gas can be a
transportation fuel we know how to do
that we ought to just get on and do it
and reduce oil imports and the lower the
use of oil in total in our society we
also have to have whatever is the
ultimate debate between uranium and
thorium is a future for nuclear fission
I have huge dependence upon ancient
nuclear reactors in this country with no
idea what we're gonna do next
other than extend the life cycle of a
nuclear reactor that's our only solution
that's gonna come to a screeching halt
when we have a meltdown somewhere
because of the age of the reactor new
book out super fuel by James Martin
ought to read it because it is the
opportunity to have a different nuclear
future because we can't get off coal we
can't get off hydrocarbons if we don't
have substitute alternatives and today's
wind and today's solar today's
geothermal which is almost nothing
today's hydropower big old silted over
dams we're not going to get there from
here based on what we've got and so it
is in the science area that I think we
have to make big breakthroughs the risk
of maybe taking us a little over time
we've been taking questions from our
satellite locations and we got one in
from Bowers Hall across the way that I
think might be a good one to end on and
I'm tempted to go in reverse order so
bill John Sheila and Jim what does the
shale gas controversy tell us about
issues of power and politics in the US
vs. issues of science as a school of
forestry and environmental studies in a
research university we face these
questions of science and management
science and policy all the time to the
extent that you all can comment on those
in this particular context that would be
I think quite interesting to our
audience bill you're willing to take a
crack first
everything to do with the fossil fuel
industry tells you where power lies this
is the one industry in the entire world
that doesn't have to pay to put out its
waste it gets to pour carbon into the
atmosphere for free and they have
defended that perc with every political
tool at their disposal for a long time
and will continue to they may accept
some small price on carbon someday but
we know now that you know to be
effective in any meaningful way it'll
have to be a hefty price on carbon one
that keeps 80 percent of current
reserves underground because any more
than that will take us past two degrees
so the the the the question before us
and I really liked what Sheila said a
minute ago but she was saying she was
more an incrementalist than I was and
that's I suppose true at this point but
it has nothing to do with my own
particular take on things I mean I'm you
know I'm a Methodist sunday-school
teacher I'm as as mild mannered as it's
possible to be in most ways it's that
it's that it's that physics isn't
incrementalist at this point what does
it tell you when the Arctic is melted
we've taken you know one of the biggest
physical features on our planet and
destroyed it in the course of 40 years
and you know name any other big physical
feature on the planet you can say about
the same thing that's what political
power looks like and the scientists told
us 25 years ago what was going to happen
and they have been proven right in every
dimension about climate change and yet
it hasn't deterred the fossil fuel
industry from doing a thing shell is
still up there pushing into the Arctic
to drill for yet more oil that's how it
works
two things one I come back to the
comment I made earlier on citizen
education we we have got to raise the
level of awareness and understanding of
the risks and the
opportunities relative to everyday
citizens and do it in ways that are
meaningful with real data not with
slogans or symbols but with real
information about the real risks and the
real opportunities secondly I don't
think we're gonna get off hydrocarbons
anytime in the next 30 40 50 years so
the effort that needs to be done from a
scientific standpoint is how do we clean
up those hydrocarbons I think there's a
huge opportunity to clean hydrocarbons
and to operate in with hydrocarbons in a
way in which there is far less emission
for example I could imagine an emission
less refinery not overnight but over a
10 20 30 year period every refinery gets
rebuilt by virtue of the capital
investment made with new process
technology new innovations new
regulations etc set the target of
mission emission 'less refineries that
would have a huge impact in places like
the Gulf Coast where the refineries are
intensely emitting into the atmosphere I
know people say you know clean coal is
an oxymoron well how do we know that how
do we actually know that until we've
tried we haven't really tried
carbon capture with sequestration with
coal gasification with 98 percent of the
emissions not emitted but rather buried
how do we know that that's not the case
when theoretically it is the case let's
see if we can do that so we have a way
with existing or known technology to try
to dramatically clean up hydrocarbons
and yes I think methane leaks from gas
wells should be stopped
we should have well inspections we
should have well reporting and that just
simply makes common sense because why
put methane into the atmosphere that you
could otherwise capture and sell
commercially you know there's a certain
commerciality here that doesn't make
sense to leak methane when that's your
source of shareholder value and so there
are a lot of things that we could do
that we aren't doing and whether it's
because the regulations aren't
sufficient or because individual
companies aren't committed to it I think
that social pressure can change all of
that and that's where informed citizens
make a difference
it's interesting to me the question is
divided you know as a powered politics
versus science I mean there couldn't
have been more science in the
application of hydraulic fracturing to
shale gas I mean you you have to think
about that as I mean I'm not I don't I
can't right I'm not a cardiologist and
I'm not a petroleum engineer so I can't
make the comparison that John made
earlier and be you know in a careful way
but you have to think about the fact
that this resource the sort of vast new
you know newly economic domestic
resource it was almost there which just
wasn't economic to extract is largely
the product of two things one high
energy prices at the time right we're
talking about a future of very expensive
natural gas in the US and so the price
was gonna be that high mean it's just
like you might learn in a sort of 101
natural resource economics class well
that drives this this process of private
research and development exploration
trying to apply these new technologies
to existing resources but it was also
the product of large public investments
so if you sort of look at the history
the development of the technology itself
no matter which resource is being
applied to there's a huge federal
investment in that as well the
Department of Energy and and other and
other institutions so this question of
you know is power power and politics or
science I mean this is all science the
problem is that that we don't really at
least in my view have sufficient science
on the social cost side to say whether
right on the whole this is the the right
direction or if it's not then how should
we tweak it to make it the right
direction so I also appreciate John's
point about R&D right it's just that
this here is an example of that in full
swing right this is the product of
massive R&D investments on both in the
private sector in the public sector and
what incentivize that at least and on
the private side was was high prices and
those same forces will are driving
investments in renewables and research
and renewables right and so you know I
think a part of the question is how is
that going to sort of play out over time
so that you know if this is in fact a
transition fuel right so that we're in
in place at the next transit
right for renewables to have benefited
from the same kinds of investments so I
think the the role of R&D is critical
it's just that you know sometimes R&D
produces something that is you know is a
little bit different than what you might
be thinking of if you're talking about
you know the low-carbon future and you
know here we are this is we have shale
gas and think there are lots of pros
I'll leave it at that
Jim I want to talk and by talking about
science in relationship to the New York
state moratorium moratorium was placed
on shale gas development there because
that they thought that there was a
dearth of science and so supplemental
generic environmental impact statement
was written was commented on it was
revised now it looks like there's a good
possibility that they will open parts of
New York State up at least five counties
in the southern tier to shale gas
development so the notion behind that
moratorium was we need to learn more we
don't know enough about the
environmental impacts that's a concern
okay so we went through this process
over a year long you look at truly the
new science that's available after that
year compared to what we knew then
there's not much of a difference there
hasn't been a great deal of new science
generated more people have talked about
it there's been greater debate but
they're debating the same old thing and
so science has a role but science isn't
ruling the day in terms of the shale gas
development issue unfortunately that's
all the time we have for today's panel
for this wonderfully rich discussion
that didn't come anywhere near close to
covering all of the questions that had
been sent in online and raised in the
other rooms which is why the organizers
of this event are going to be hosting a
series of continuing conversations as
well as posting some answer
some of the questions online if you go
to the URL up on the screen that'll be a
good place to to track these events
I just got notice of one at 7:30 tonight
at the Yale political Union where bill
will be talking about why should why
Yale should divest from fossil fuels in
just a minute we'll be inviting you all
to a reception out at the other end of
the floor but before that I hope you'll
join me in thanking our panelists for a
wonderful discussion